in Lucia the baubles are still blown by
hand in the run-up to Christmas the
fragile artworks can be seen wherever
you go the lousy Christmas tree
decorations market takes place on the
first two weekends of Advent visitors
come from far and wide it's a feast for
the eyes
each Balban is more beautiful than the
last it warms your heart really
beautiful many customers prefer handmade
Christmas ornaments to mass-produced
industrial ones there's a lot of
competition but these remain very
popular many customers want reassurance
that they really are made in laos
alongside bubbles glass birds are also
extremely popular and trumpets are
traditional I remember when they were
put under the Christmas tree
cones like these and the nuts as well
defense toy I think it's great here the
snow adds to the lovely atmosphere would
you aspire and there are unusual items
the emojis
I came all the way from the North Pole
to see the real craftsmanship here how
the baubles are blown by hand do
business with key players in Viet Minh
craftspeople have been working with
glass in Lucia for over 400 years the
village grew up around the Glass Works
Christmas ornaments were first made in
the middle of the 19th century the
town's museum of glass art has many old
treasures on display exports began early
many went to Pennsylvania in the US but
why did the people here start making
Christmas ornaments legend has it that a
poor glass blower has no apples or nuts
that's what people back then used to
decorate the tree he couldn't afford to
buy any so he made his own ornaments
from glass glass Christmas ornaments
came about right here in Lao Hamish
mocks today there are five glass blowers
here who are specialised in Christmas
ornaments Michel Holland is one of them
he still uses molds made by his
grandfather labels photos my grandfather
made many birds in his life my mother
always said that if all those birds were
to wake up and fly away it would darken
the sky over Laos under a mixture of
silver and ammonia is put into the glass
mold then the works are dried and
painted Michelle Harlan produces mainly
birds but he has many other shapes as
well
there's a huge variety of Christmas
ornaments on sale at the class works in
Lucia and they're there all year round
even when it's not cold and snowy
outside
we've already found Christmas baubles
these are the ones on the short list
I like the Santa's best the glass works
here especial my daughter asked us to
get these and she wanted something from
Laos lower home christmas is coming and
the glassblowers of lao sure will help
make it a season of light and good shear